as letras lançavam para nenhum
ele tinha muitos problemas com a leitura
ea escrita
os professores diziam que ele não tinha
interesse em aprender
ele só queria brincadeira tinha que
chamar se de público e por diversas
vezes ele expõe sala sozinho fazendo
presente
ninguém nunca perguntou o que ele podia
ter ninguém nunca pensa gente que
acontece com esse menino sempre diziam
que não tinha interesse em meu irmão na
verdade ele tinha a dizer se ele tem
dislexia e o que a dislexia é gente
direita e cia
é um distúrbio ao paok a pessoa não
consegue aprender a ler nem escrever
ela as letras na verdade são códigos nas
gentes e elas não conseguem distinguir
esses códigos ea têm muita dificuldade
para conseguir aprender a ler e escrever
para vocês terem uma ideia hoje no nosso
país não existe nenhuma política pública
para incluir pessoas com dislexia que
seja inclusivo e no ano de 2008 teve a
portaria número 6 o dia 5 de junho de
2008 onde o mec não decide basicamente
nada sobre o que fazer sobre a desafia
isso prejudica muito quem vende
beneficia prejudica na escola prejudica
socialmente prejudica o universitário
ambiente que como que eu vou chegar na
universidade sendo que eu não consigo
aprender a ler e escrever e todo mundo
falava que meu irmão queria nada e mesmo
todo mundo falando isso a minha mãe
nunca desistiu ela nunca pensou meu
filho realmente não quer nada e ela
sempre buscou explicações para isso com
que meu filho no encarnada todos os
professores falam que ele não quer
aprender a de que ele só quer fazer
bagunça e nessas buscas que ela fez ela
encontrou o chamado dever se ia que se
encaixava contudo que o mesmo
apresentava tudo que ele dizia
e aí ela procurou serviços não pudesse
ajudar ele e ela viu que se tratava
eram muito caros era tratamentos
demoradas então encontrou na uerj do rio
de janeiro
o serviço gratuito de fonoaudiologia e
neurologista
ela teve o primeiro diagnóstico dele
conseguiu ter o primeiro diagnóstico e
ele ingressou na escola que trabalha com
esse tipo de criança que tanto tem
dislexia distúrbio de down e lá ele
conseguiu começar a aprender a ler e
escrever e o que me levou isso em 2015
eu conheci a agência digital para a
juventude agência ela foi idealizada
pelo marketing ou cheia e nela eles
procuram protagonizar os jovens
moradores de favelas do rio de janeiro
né
e lá vou eu tive a oportunidade de expor
de falar sobre aquilo que tanto
incomodava eu pude dar voz a um assunto
que é esquecido na atuação do que muita
gente não conhece os falantes de jacques
ia dizer àquelas pessoas que bateu no
chão não não é e eu já escutei muito
insuficiente não é isso
enfim pela agência teve oportunidade de
falar sobre isso e coloca a 3 e assim eu
vou fazer um projeto com crianças é um
projeto onde vai ter contações de
histórias para as crianças com dislexia
e a partir das histórias que vão fazer
desenhos e desses desenhos da biblioteca
da minha comunidade
os pais dessas crianças
as pessoas enfim mostrar que essas
crianças é normal como eu e você que
elas têm um tecto perfeito
a única dificuldade que elas têm de
aprender a ler e escrever e no dia que
deveria de 10 ninguém acreditou na minha
idéia ninguém acreditou que ia se fosse
dar certo e eu fiquei meio chateada
fiquei muito chateada fiquei poxa
ninguém acreditou na idéia com sim mas
eu não desistir eu conheci quatro
meninas
queria fazer teatro e não você tem muito
teatro falei gente não faz uma coisa
diferenciada e também surgiram idéias
também as pessoas ficam falando com a
gente eu falei vamos fazer uma coisa
diferenciada a gente fazer teatro e
sinal teatro
vamos levar o teatro para as pessoas que
a gente decidiu levar o teatro para as
pessoas mas levar o teatro onde uma
coisa assim de gal
vamos falar sobre de chefia
vamos levar o teatro para a casa das
pessoas falando sobre dislexia
vamos ea gente procurou onde se procurou
profissionais que pudesse dar um suporte
pra gente
procuramos um diretor que supre
acreditou na nossa ideia que abraçou
nossa causa e falou vamos fazer isso
a gente foi atrás de atores que crianças
da emoção que a gente queria levar as
pessoas a gente não queria fazer
palestra a gente não queria chegar e
falar de flexibilidade isso esses não há
gente queria mostrar como vive uma
pessoa tem de ver se ia o que passa uma
pessoa de lexi o descaso que ela vive
então a gente fez seis cenas voltadas
pra isso e não sei se a gente mostrou
histórias tanto da mãe tanto do pai
tanto do menino que tem dislexia e na
primeira cena que a gente fez foi a cena
do pai
a cena do pai ele fala sobretudo a moto
do carinho que ele tem pelo filho dele
isso tudo antes dele descobrir que o
filho dele tinha a dizer cia
ele falava sobre como filho dele era o
cotidiano dele dentro de casa com as
crianças na cena da mãe a mãe falava
sobre o filho dela orgulho que ela
sentia pelo filho dela a nunca desistir
do filho dela ela falava que o filho
dela é uma criança especial o menino
lindo
tinha muito orgulho desse filho e que
ela não quer desistir desse filho belo
na cela do menino o menino conta toda
essa trajetória na escola com os amigos
ele fala tudo que ele sentia
tudo que ele passava por ser uma criança
de lex ser um adolescente de 17
e a gente tem a cena da mãe na laje e do
menino na laje
elas são da mesma forma da mãe e do
menino
só que de uma forma corporal e em lages
estão em seu nome menino e mãe na laje
estamos a cena desafia a cena desse a
gente traz todo o contexto da dislexia
tudo o que a diretoria possam tratamento
da dislexia toda a gente traz nessa cena
mas de uma forma brincou brincadeiras
a gente fala sobre o professor como é
tratada essa pessoa pelo professor
a gente fala sobre o olhar que ele tem
sobre os amigos gente fala sobre
reportagens sobre tudo a gente fala ali
naquele contexto da cena de flexível e
depois de todas essas cenas
a gente conversava em que fazia um
lanche com todos que estavam ali ia
bater papo conversar explicar e falar
olha gente assim nesse momento a gente
falava dislexia isso esses dislexia é
injusto não é uma doença é uma onde
estuda onde a pessoa não consegue
aprender a ler e escrever
a gente ficava todo o contexto das
delegacia explicar vá aonde ela podia
levar aquela criança tratamento em que
falava sobre escolas que apoiar nossas
crianças lugares que tratavam as
crianças de forma gratuita
a gente passava tudo isso e durante
todas as apresentações de esteves passou
por 12 casas nessas quase sempre
procurou levar pessoas que pudessem
levar as informações foram passadas
também pra outras ea gente sempre buscou
levar pessoas é é agente de saúde da
nossa comunidade professores da região
de escolas públicas
jovens que participam de projetos da
localidade e os moradores levavam quem
estiver sem que eles quisessem levar
lhes podia levar eu sempre escutei
muitas coisas assim que me ajudou demais
porque eu sempre escutei assim
gente eu conheço a pessoa pode ter
só eu tenho um primo que eu acho que
pode ter isso e nunca ninguém procurou
saber em qual você fala aí nunca ninguém
busca saber quem foi que não tinha
interesse
olha meu irmão pode ter e isso também eu
acho que meu irmão
cara eu preciso da sua ajuda me ajuda de
algum jeito
o que mais me emocionou que me deixou
mais emocionado que eleva se para minha
vida foi uma mãe uma avó que na verdade
ela nervosa ela é uma mãe porque ela
crise meninas da esquina a seguir e
nunca teve contato com a mãe quando ela
assistia à cena do menino ela pra mim
muito emocionado ao final falou assim eu
vi meu filho aí eu vi o meu neto aí tudo
que você falou que o neto passa
os professores reclamam do mesmo jeito
já não sei mais o que fazer e vendo essa
cena eu vi que meu neto pode ter isso eu
tive uma resposta que uma resposta que
eu nunca imaginei que meu filho meu neto
poderia ter isso eu nunca nunca ninguém
veio pra mim falar sobre dizer se a ele
já saiu de escolas
por conta disso que as pessoas reclamam
muito dele e aquilo me deixou muito
abalado porque eu estava levando uma
informação para a pessoa que ela nunca
teve e ela estava quase desistindo
daquele neto dela porque ela não sabia
mais o que fazer
ela não sabia o que o neto dela tinha
ela não sabe onde buscar respostas e uma
senhora sozinha criam do menino sem
saber o que fazer e eu tive a satisfação
de poder falar assim gente eu faço eu
estou ajudando as pessoas realmente eu
estou ajudando as pessoas e para vocês
terem noção
segundo a bt que essa seleção brasileira
de dislexia de 5 a 17 por cento da
população mundial tende a crescer e no
brasil 10% das pessoas tem dislexia e
não tem nenhum dado de corpos por cento
enquanto quantos desses 10% estão o
tratamento ninguém sabe quantas pessoas
já assistiram tratamento
então vamos pensar disse
por cento quantos porcento dessas
pessoas estão por aí na rua
desinteressados por não conseguir
aprender a ler e por ninguém acreditar
que elas não conseguem estão por aí eu
estou na favela virão do traficante
ouviram do assaltante ouviram do morador
de rua que não é compreendido quando as
pessoas estão por aí
dessa forma e o que eu tenho a dizer pra
vocês que hoje o meu irmão tem 16 anos e
graças à minha mãe que nunca desistiu
dele nunca acreditou que ele era
desinteressada
hoje ele sabe lê hoje ele sabe escrever
e editar 8ª série que ela nunca desistiu
de o meu irmão
as letras voltavam pra ele
a gente tem que prestar atenção para ver
se á à direita de mudança para quem está
do nosso lado
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]